Das war's für heute.
Also, wer denkt, dass wir jetzt anfangen können? Lol.
So einfach ist es natürlich nicht.
The GPU instance has been suspended. Aha, das ist sehr interessant.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass meine Grafiker sich ausschalten kann.
Da müssen wir das Game nochmal neu starten und nochmal neu die Mikrofon-Settings machen, weil das Game nie wieder umstellen wird gleich.
Lol. Einfach nur Lol. Lol 3D.
Übrigens, mir fällt gerade auf, Twitch hat sich bei mir auf Twitch Beta umgestellt, sehe ich gerade im Browser.
Und jetzt geht Beta-Twitch-TV nicht mehr. Das muss ich umstellen.
Das muss ich umstellen. Das geht nämlich nicht.
Ohne Beta-Twitch-TV kann ich den Chat nicht lesen, das ist nicht möglich.
Aber man kann Beta ausschalten, das ist gut.
Jetzt mal Kanal refreshen und jetzt sollte ich auch wieder Beta-Twitch-TV-Emails haben.
Hoffe ich.
Na ja, geht das jetzt? Probieren wir mal aus.
Ja, funktioniert. Perfekt.
Nice.
Richtig nice.
So, es ist noch relativ früh, ich muss noch aufwachen.
Was gibt es besseres zu mal aufwachen, als eine neue Runde Lol 3D zu spielen?
PokChamp-Best-Champ.
Jetzt fehlen bloß noch diese Benutzernamen, so was nach dem Motto irgendwie, notify me when Max dies, so irgendwie sowas.
Was ist der Trend in größeren Channels zur Zeit?
Oder whisper me when an A-Old oder sowas in der Richtung.
Gut, jetzt habe ich wenigstens wieder Emails. Das ist wichtig. Ohne Emails, ohne Beta-Twitch-TV-Emails geht nichts.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste.
So, jetzt haben wir Wasser.
Dann wollen wir mal, würde ich sagen. Go, go.
Wir gucken uns erst noch mal, das wollte ich nämlich das letzte Mal schon machen, mal Vollbild einschalten.
Aber noch gucken, ob das auch meine Grafik-Settings beibehalten hat.
Den Scheiß nicht einfach ausschalten.
Brauchen wir alles nicht, brauchen wir alles nicht.
Was auch immer.
Shadows, wer braucht Shadows?
Shadows, komm jetzt.
Ich brauche keine Shadows. Ich will, dass das, ich brauche mehr FPS.
Meine Grafikkarte ist zu schlecht. Das ist nicht die teuerste Grafikkarte, die es gibt, aber zu schlecht für das Game.
Am besten ist ja, dass ich überhaupt keine Ahnung habe, was uns diese Optionen eigentlich alles sagen sollen.
Quality Shadows, Lul, da brauchst du was. Shadows off.
Obwohl, Shadows sind manchmal ganz praktisch, weil man schon sieht, dass einer um die Ecke kommt, bevor man ihn sieht.
Shadows lassen wir mal an.
Ja, Texturfilter, Zeugs, machen wir nochmal.
Keine Ahnung.
Nein, das will ich nicht.
Textur stellen wir mal nur auf High, auch nochmal auf High runter, auch nochmal auf High runter.
Komm, wir stellen es mal auf Normal. Wir gucken mal, ob das Auswirkungen auf die Performance hat.
Weil die Performance das letzte Mal war wirklich grottenschlecht.
Und dann wollte ich nochmal den Soldat anpassen.
Oh, das ist nicht einfach nur Airborne, das ist Airborne HD.
Airborne HD.
Was nehmen wir denn mal? Was kann man hier schönes anlocken?
Ich hoffe ja insgeheim immer noch, dass das die einzigen Waffen sind.
HQ, nein, nein, das ist HD. Die haben es bestimmt nur verschrieben.
Ich hoffe immer noch, dass es die einzigen Waffen sind, die es geben wird am Ende, aber ich glaube es ja nicht.
Dann wäre das nämlich wirklich das mal halbwegs sinnvoll zu balancen.
So, was kann man machen? Nehmen wir mal das Ding.
Wo sehe ich eigentlich meine Tokens? 13 Tokens, ja, kommen wir mal das Ding.
Wenigstens haben sie auf Ingame-Waffen-Statistiken gleich verzichtet.
Weil die Ingame-Waffen-Statistiken waren eh immer kaputt.
Irgendwie sieht das Bild nicht so aus wie die Waffe, oder?
Ne, wirklich.
Ah, okay, das heißt, die Aufsätze muss man sich frei spielen mit der Waffe.
Okay, okay, na dann leveln wir das Ding erst nochmal ein bisschen, dann haben wir da Aufsätze.
Oh, Scopes.
Ob sowas im Zweiten Weltkrieg schon gab?
Aim Downside Faster.
Gibt es sowas wie Quick, Quick, wie hieß das so? Nach dem Sprint ein schneller Waffe ziehen?
Or Rapid Fire? Nice, nice, nice.
Dann spielen wir erst mal das hier mit frei. Quick Draw.
Was kannst du mir bei meinem PC helfen? Habt ihr ein Problem? Das ist Remote immer so ein bisschen schwierig, ne?
Ach, hier unten steht dann auch, was die Waffe kann.
Das ist einfach immer gelogen. Das ist in allen Games so, die tun so, als würde ein Visier darauf das Ganze genauer machen, was ja Blödsinn ist.
Das macht es auch nicht genauer. Und die Range wird auch nicht höher. Man sieht es einfach nur besser.
Oh, Steady Aim, das brauch ich. Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt Quick Draw, Faster und besser aus Hüfte da. Das klingt eigentlich ganz gut.
Probieren wir das mal in der Kombination.
Pistolen gibt es nur zwei.
Granaten gibt es.
Easy, auf gehts.
Spielen wir mal eine Runde Team Deathmatch zum Warmwerden.
Oh, das ging aber schnell.
Spray and pray, klar.
Oh, da gibt es viele Comments, aber ich muss dir das mal beschreiben.
Vor allem, dass wir wach werden.
Die Musik dabei.
Wo ist der Gegner?
Übrigens, die Shotgun soll richtig OP sein.
Die Shotgun mit Brandmunition soll richtig OP sein, habe ich gelesen.
Rekt.
Die spawnen bestimmt jetzt hier.
Mal gucken, wie der Sound ist.
Guck, da ist schon einer, da ist einer.
What the fuck.
Sample Name, was fuckt, du willst ab? Meinst du Shotgun?
Oh, ich glaube der Sound.
Alter, ich glaube es nicht.
Der PC-Port ist so abgefuckt, ey.
Guck dir das mal an.
Also selten sowas Abgefucktes gesehen.
Das Game crash laufend.
Mr. Milchmann, nee, seit 5 Minuten oder so.
Dann müssen wir jetzt besonders leise reden, weil das Game ja gerne die Mikrofon-Settings umstellt.
Swift Rage.
Also das habe ich noch nie erlebt, dass ein Game wirklich so oft und so unberechenbar abkackt.
Da war Battlefield 4 bei Release nichts dagegen.
Mir fällt jetzt nichts ein, was so instabil war in letzter Zeit, wie World War 2 hier.
Was ist Remote? Remote ist eine Fernbedienung.
Oder was meinste? Hä? What?
Also ich sage, wenn das Game nicht besser läuft, kaufe ich mir das garantiert nicht.
Ich weiß ja nicht ein, dass das alle zweimal in der Runde abscheißt.
SilentPain sagt, bei mir schützt es nie ab, aber Mikro-Rockler.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was nerviger ist.
Da ist auch Schneiber am Start hier.
Und wisst ihr, was ich wirklich schlimm finde?
Was ich richtig schlimm finde, ist, dass es keine Finger-Anzeige gibt.
Sowas macht man nur, wenn man was verstecken will.
Das macht man nicht einfach so.
Das macht man nur, wenn man irgendwas verstecken will.
Wenn man will, dass die Leute irgendwas nicht sehen.
Wenn man quasi so tun will, als gibt es gute Verbindungen, aber gibt es nicht.
Oder so.
Wir fallen einfach drauf.
Da hinten ist ein Gegner. Den flanken wir jetzt.
Flankerino.
Achtung, den schneiden wir jetzt.
Komm her.
Oh, fuck.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich P2P? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Angeblich, angeblich nicht.
Aber ich glaube denen nichts, weil es gab bei Call of Duty Ghosts ja auch Dedicated Servers on all Platforms.
Und gab es bis zum Schluss nicht.
Also ich glaube denen nichts in der Richtung.
Ich glaube denen gar nichts.
Also für mich fühlt sich das nicht so an.
Ich habe auf Reddit schon gelesen, dass Leute Host-Migration hatten.
Das komplett dagegen spricht, dass es eigene Servers sind.
Ups, da ist ein Gegner.
Diese alle versuchen mich auch zu strafeln ey.
Kacknuts.
Der hat schreckt.
Der hat noch mehr schreckt.
Tyrannosaurus schreckt.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier? Was ist das?
Oh.
Okay, darüber hat keiner Ahnung, wie man gerade ausschießen kann.
Was ist das hier?
Ah, das ist die Bombe.
Oh, nice.
Kann man Gas geben mit dem Gegner?
Ich finde es besser.
Eigentlich kann ich hier einfach stehen bleiben und in eine Richtung.
Oh, hier kann man sich schönlich verstecken und dann Artillerie drauf legen.
Bam.
Jetzt werden sie gestreckt.
Bam, guck, er ist da schon weg.
Krach in your face.
Noch mehr in your face.
Richtig gebashed jetzt.
Okay, typische Call of Duty Map Ende.
Man weiß einfach nicht, warum die Map hier zu Ende ist.
Und warum man da sowas reinstellen sollte.
Spray and pray, das ist ja das größte Spray and pray Game von allen bisher.
Ich stelle mich mal wieder an meine...
Spray and pray.
Spray and pray ist todenseitig.
Okay, ich lese mal den Chat.
Was?
WWPDD.
Oh, das war eine lange Nachricht.
Wenn ich mein PC starte, dann geht es direkt ins BIOS.
Okay.
Und da macht so ein komisches regelmäßiges Geräusch.
So als würde die Festplatte starten wollen, schafft es aber nicht.
Kann das am Lüfter liegen oder was?
Letztens war meine Festplatte auch schon kaputt.
Die habe ich gewechselt.
Jetzt ging es wieder, aber diesmal ist das Geräusch anders als bei der Festplatte.
Denn die Festplatte startet nicht mehr, sondern direkt ins BIOS.
Also direkt ins BIOS liegt er in der Regel daran, dass er nicht findet, von was er booten kann.
Zumindest machen das viele Rechner.
Was damit zusammenpassen wird, dass seine Festplatte im Arsch ist.
Oder zumindest, wenn du sagst, es läuft an, dass das...
Ich sehe keine Probleme mit der Stromversorgung.
Keine Ahnung, es hört sich an, als würde der Motor nicht richtig anlaufen.
Aber da kann man wie immer auch nichts dagegen sagen.
Ich würde es einfach mal an einen anderen Stecker stoppseln.
Ich würde andere Stromkabel dran machen.
Am besten von einer anderen Leitung, vom Netzteil.
Den SATA-Port mal wechseln.
Im Zweifelsfall einfach mal einen SATA-Stecker pusten.
Das geht immer gegen vorbei.
Super Nintendo Cartridges.
Ja, und dann geht es weiter.
Nein, das bringt nichts, den Stecker zu pusten.
Aber den Stromstecker kannst du mal wechseln.
Und SATA-Kabel vielleicht.
Oder anderen SATA-Port.
Und wenn das nichts hilft, würde ich mal versuchen, von einer Live-CD zu booten.
Beziehungsweise von einem Live-USB-Stick.
Und zu gucken, ob er die Platte erkennt.
Und so.
Das kann man, wie immer, wirklich schwer was dazu sagen.
Also Silent Pain, der Quickscope-Faktor in dem Spiel, ist relativ hoch.
Vor allem, wenn man diesen Objective-Modus spielt.
Da kann man sich nämlich den Arsch absnipen an der einen Stelle, wo man die Brücke bauen muss.
Aber richtig den Arsch absnipen.
Auf beiden Seiten.
Das ist der Traum für alle krassen Sniper.
Für alle, die gerne im Faceclan werden, es einfach nicht packen.
Für die ist das das Beste.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, aktuell so balance-technisch.
Was übelst gut ist, ist Prey & Prey aus der Hüfte mit SMGs, hat man gerade gesehen.
Vor allem, weil man in dem Spiel schön AD-AD-Strafen kann.
Fast so schön wie in Overwatch.
Ansonsten, was halt mega OP ist, ist die Shotgun zur Zeit.
Shotgun mit dieser Brand-Munition drinnen.
Was richtig kacke sein muss, ist die doppelläufige Shotgun.
Habe ich aber nur gelesen, habe ich schon ausprobiert.
Ich mache mir gleich mal eine klasse Shotgun mit Brand-Munition.
Das gucken wir uns gleich mal an.
Ja, frag den Nilshorn, der erkennt sich aus mit sowas.
Als wo ich ihn gerade sehe.
Jetzt erstmal den Schalldämpfer dran.
Irgendwie sieht das Model übelst scheiße aus.
Das sieht mega scheiße aus.
Das ist hier Flanker-Action.
Krasse Flanker-Action.
Die kommen jetzt hier links gleich.
Der denkt, ich laufe links, guck, der denkt, ich laufe links.
Den haben wir jetzt aber outplayed.
Gebatet haben wir den, gebatet.
Komm, der hat die Ecke gejumpt.
Da hat er seine Scuff-Maus angeschlossen.
Der Sound ist auch ein bisschen unberechenbar.
Man kann nämlich, obwohl man sieht, die Team-Mats sind hinter einem,
aber trotzdem hört es sich so an, als sind die vor einem und sowas.
Ganz, ganz komisch.
Jetzt höre ich rechts was, keine Ahnung, ob wirklich rechts was ist.
Okay, rechts ist was.
Ähm, NA-Nade.
Spray and pray, guckt euch das mal an, wie krass die Waffen aus der Hüfte sind.
Ich schieße jetzt nur aus der Hüfte, ich muss mir das angucken.
Wie OP, wie OP Spray and pray aus der Hüfte ist.
Black Desert ist im Sale, sollte man sich das gönnen.
Klar, wenn man MMOs mag und vor allem MMOs, die nicht so dieses übliche Raid-Endgame haben.
Ey, das ist so OP.
Das ist nicht normal.
Da komme ich mit meiner Waffe nicht hin über die Range.
Die flanken wir jetzt.
Oh fuck, fuck.
Zu viel Spray and pray, aber das Ding ist übelst gut.
Umge-Strafe.
Diesmal läuft es ja ganz toll.
Der Typ ist immer noch hinten, TF.
Jetzt kann er nicht mehr hier sein, wenn die Leute spawnen.
Also ich muss sagen, das Spray and pray aus der Hüfte ist wirklich krass.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von wo die kommen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was?
Ja, das stimmt.
Der Schalldampfer macht es ziemlich schwach über Range.
Aber ich will das jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Wir mussten es ja mal ein bisschen testen.
Dafür ist ja so eine Beta auch da.
Einfach mal gucken, mit was man gut klarkommt und was gut funktioniert.
Ich könnte ja permanent die OP Kombination spielen, das geht ja auch.
Achtung hier, Achtung jetzt hier.
Skill-Nade.
Oder auch nicht.
Oh, der ist tot.
Aber jetzt rüberpushen.
Guckt euch mal das aus der Hüfte an, so krass.
Aber der Schalldampfer ist wirklich kacke.
Der War-Modus ist cool.
Das einzige Problem, was ich mit dem War-Modus habe, ist, dass ich finde, es sind fast ein bisschen zu viele Spieler für die Map-Kurse.
Okay, jetzt hören wir mal mit der Hüfte-Spray-and-Pray-Geschichte auf.
Kann man hier rüber?
Diese alle ihre krassen Face-Moves machen.
Was ist denn das?
Oh, meine Granate war es gekillt.
Ich charge jetzt durch.
Warte, wo sind die alle hin?
Ich habe jetzt richtig geile Flank gemacht, alles weg.
Sind die alle tot?
Voll durchgeflankt.
Aber die kommen hier jetzt gleich.
Der Sound, wenn man einen killt, das gefällt mir sogar ganz gut.
Das fühlt sich so an, als würde etwas passieren.
Ah, ich habe ja ein paar Killstreaks.
Guck mal, wo der herkommt.
Achtung, da oben kommt gleich noch einer.
Den lauen wir jetzt hier mal auf.
Richtig schön Camp-Act.
Ein bisschen Head-Clitchen noch.
Head-Clitch ist real.
Ich warte jetzt hier einfach.
Kommt aber nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ist der Typ hin?
Wo ist er?
Da gehen wir nicht durch, das ist viel zu lang da unten.
Die meisten stehen einfach nur rum, was ist mit denen los?
Durch Chargen, durch Chargen, da kennen wir nichts.
Sniper.
Oh, der wird gebashed.
Ich wollte den Nahkampf gebashed und habe die falsche Taste gedrückt.
Ich habe F gedrückt aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Was ist in Nahkampf noch mal gewesen?
Ach, V.
Und wenn man die falsche Taste drückt?
V, das ist ja richtig kacke.
Ich muss Nahkampf wieder auf rechte Maustaste machen.
Einzig sinnvolle.
Ah, schöner Call of Duty-Tot, in Rücken geschossen.
Ich komme jetzt gleich von hier vorne.
Null.
Reckt.
Die Maps finde ich ganz gut bis jetzt, muss ich sagen.
Die Maps finde ich wirklich ganz gut.
Nicht 3 Milliarden Wege, aber genug.
So, mal Chat lesen.
Welche CPU hast du? Ich habe aktuell noch eine...
Wer ist das?
Ich habe aktuell noch einen Xeon V...
Nein, ein Xeon 1230 V3.
Sehr griffiger Name.
Ich höre es im Hintergrund bimmeln.
So, was können wir noch mal...
Was können wir noch mal ausrüsten?
Wir machen uns jetzt wirklich mal so eine OP.
Gibt es eigentlich unterschiedliche Waffen zwischen...
Zwischen, sagen wir, Infan 3 und... Nee, nicht wirklich.
Wir machen uns danach mal eine OP-Klasse mit Shotgun.
Probieren wir mal aus, ob das wirklich so OP ist.
Also, als wir vorgestern diesen Objective-Modus gespielt haben,
da war natürlich Shotgun auf den engen Gebieten total OP, also maßlos OP.
Will gleiche Map.
Hallo, Leute. Kommt ins Game.
Ich muss... Moment, ich muss... Ah, wichtig.
Controls.
Keep it in X. Nahkampf.
Maus 4. Das ist auch wieder so was, was 100 pro dem Konsolenport geschuldet ist,
dass man nicht zwei Tasten einfach zuweisen kann.
Weil sau viele Games hatten früher und auch immer noch doppelt...
Also, du konntest quasi Haupt-Taste festlegen und Alternative.
Was jetzt nicht mehr funktioniert. Mal gucken, da flenkt uns was.
Lul, outplayed.
Da rechts war was, rechts war was. Der wird jetzt gebashed rechts.
Wo ist hier was?
Ich hab den... Ach so, es ist gar kein Gegner in Game.
Okay, also kaum Gegner drinne.
Das würde es natürlich erklären,
dass wir nix sehen an Gegner, wenn hier irgendwie nix in dem Game drinne ist.
Zack, aber.
Ich höre was?
Gott, es sackt es.
Off range mit dem Schall...
Ich höre doch was.
Ach, das sind jetzt meine Teammates.
What? What? Was war das denn?
Ah, gescheit.
So, jetzt ist das Game wenigstens voll.
Das strafe movement ist auch komisch.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Bad Company.
Also wenn man dieses Rennstrafen, das ist ein bisschen wie in Bad Company.
Ich zeig es euch mal.
Alter, wenn du so geradeaus rennst, dann links und rechts trafest,
dann rennst du weiter geradeaus, aber so...
Was ist da oben?
Heckt. Heckt.
Hat er mich gesehen oder nicht?
Das ist so OP, das aus der Hüfte gesprayt.
Der denkt jetzt, er kann mich da oben drinauen.
Komm her.
Warum ist der Typ nicht abgehauen?
Warum ist der Typ nicht von meiner Granate weggerannt?
Gerade ist er irgendwie total im Scheuern oder was?
Und was ich komisch finde, diese Holovisierer,
irgendwie verbinde ich den Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mit Holovisieren.
Oder? Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Meint ihr, euer Opa hatte einen Holovisier?
Hau.
Ich weiß echt noch nicht, was ich von dem Game halten soll.
Also so Gunn technisch und sowas macht das wirklich Spaß.
Aber irgendwie so das...
Der Spielfluss ist irgendwie komisch.
Ich kann das noch nicht so richtig in Worte fassen.
Hallo, wie viele Headshots halten die aus?
Komm her.
Und halt die typischen Call of Duty Tote, dass man immer von hinten stirbt.
Ich lese gleich die Sachen im Chat.
Ein bisschen auf das Game konzentrieren.
Was hat mich da jetzt so getroffen?
Der rennt mir bestimmt hinterher.
Ist klar.
Pistole habe ich doch gerade ausprobiert.
Bin ich erster mit meinen krassen 11 zu 7 Stats. Wahnsinn.
Den hinteren Teil der Map verwendet irgendwie gar keiner, so recht habe ich das Gefühl.
Den holen wir uns.
Der hat gebashed.
Das ist OP, das ist das hüftige Spray ey, krasse Scheiße.
Mal hören.
Hier ist nichts.
Ich bleib mal hier drinnen.
Den hat man gehört.
Das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich gut, dass man die Gegner mittlerweile wieder ordentlich hört.
Und ordentlich Flank Action machen kann.
Die müssen doch jetzt hier immer spawnen. Machen sie aber nicht.
Ist kein Bock.
Flanken wir mal außen rechts.
Wenn wir jetzt hier weiter gehen müssen, wäre das direkt durch den ganzen Hof durch.
Wir warten jetzt mal auf einer.
Das Orten ist komisch. Der Typ da oben hat sich angehört, als kommt er von da.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Jetzt sind die FPS ganz okay, seitdem ich ein bisschen Grafik runtergestellt habe heute Morgen.
Aber es ist immer noch nicht angemessen für eine 1080 Ti, finde ich.
Da kann ich auf Long Range nicht kontesten mit meiner.
Weg hier, weg hier.
Wo spawnet hier was?
Oh, die werden aber direkt von der Artillerie.
Leute werden hier gespawnet.
Boah, perfekt.
Super.
Was haben wir schon da eigentlich? Ah, das ist das UAV.
Ich kann hier nicht raus, kriege ich auch einen Sack.
Gehen wir jetzt mal hier links hoch. Alles voll, alles voll.
Oh fuck, jetzt sehen sie, dass ich da bin.
Läuft das Spiel auf DirectX 12? Ich glaube nicht.
Ich denke nicht, dass es auf DirectX 12 läuft.
Was auch ein bisschen merkwürdig wäre, wenn das auf der Xbox, na gut, es läuft, na gut, ne, glaube ich nicht.
Zumal einfach nur DirectX 12, ohne dass man weiß, wie es geht, bringt dir ja auch jetzt nichts.
Ich meine, nur wenn du eine andere Technologie verwendest, mit der du potentiell was mehr rausholen könntest,
und du nicht weißt, wie du die benutzt, kann dein Spiel trotzdem schlechter laufen als mit der alten.
Das Gespray ist bei Battlefield 1 mindestens genauso krass.
Ja, das war auch ein Grund, warum ich keinen Bock auf Battlefield 1 hatte.
Also was ich ganz merkwürdig fand in Battlefield 1, waren die einen Waffen, die quasi genauer geworden sind, umso mehr du sprayst.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, hä, das habe ich ja eh noch keinem Game gesehen.
Und das andere waren die Assault Rifles, die quasi nicht dahin geschossen haben, wo du hingezielt hast.
Also quasi wie Suppression in Battlefield 3, bloß eingebaut in die Waffe.
Und da habe ich mir gesagt, ne Leute, das kann ich mir in Battlefield, das kann ich mir nicht geben.
Deswegen habe ich mir Battlefield 1 auch nicht gekauft.
So, wir wollten uns eine OP-Shotgun-Klasse machen.
OP-Shotgun-Klasse.
Panzerschreck!
Was von den... Wo kann man eigentlich... Ich meine, ich habe mich mit OP-Sachen in dem Game noch nicht beschäftigt.
Äh, welche Waffe hat denn... Oder wo kann man denn diese Brand-Munition auswählen?
Ich muss mir das jetzt mal angucken, ob das wirklich so OP ist.
Weiß das jemand, welche Shotgun das ist und was man dafür auswählen muss?
Ich muss jetzt auch mal OP-Kombination testen.
Oh, jetzt wird es geschockt dann.
Panzerklasse, war das? Okay.
Also die hier, oder was?
Ist das Brand-Munition?
Ja!
Oh, das probiere ich jetzt mal aus.
Das probiere ich jetzt mal aus.
Lol!
Oh, das war das.
Das probiere ich jetzt mal aus. Das probiere ich jetzt mal aus. Lol!
Was ist das? Was ist das?
Okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen sehr weit.
Wir müssen jetzt mal OP-Zeug ausprobieren.
Wir flanken da jetzt rein.
Waschen die.
Alter! Was ist das?
Was ist das für eine Range mit der Shotgun?
What the fuck?
Und warum liegt der Typ da rum?
WTF?
Was ist das?
What the fuck ist das?
Warum hat das so eine große Range?
Whoa!
Ich würde mich gerne mal regnen.
Ah! Man hat nur vier.
Das geht ja eigentlich.
Let's ALLFT!
Wie ist das vorallem churchesack?
Was hat der eigentlich?
Komm her!
Shotgun, Alter!
Schaut euch das mal an!
Nooo
Schreiner übrigens kann einfach sinnlos durch, ne?
Pass auf, die kriegen jetzt die Bombe auf den Kopf!
Kann man Gas geben? Kann man Gas geben?
Bam!
Schreckt!
Wir warten jetzt hier einfach, wir warten jetzt hier bis der Typ lang kommt
und dann wird er gebashed
Dreck!
Shotgun!
Wie OP ist denn das Ding, ey?
Okay
Lege OP, balanced, balanced, balanced
Richtig balanced
Äh, da!
Keine Ahnung, da sitzt ein guter
guter Spotwaffe, oh, da ist einer
Hier kann ich nicht rüber rennen mit Shotgun
Sack, Achtung!
Hä?
Tyrannosaurus rekt war das wieder
Rekt!
Rekt! Alter, die Shotgun!
Was ist das?
Ist das Ding hier ernst, ja?
Also, jetzt ernsthaft, die Shotgun ist schon echt massiv OP
Ich lese gleich die Frage, Alter
Äh, hoferdilox, was hältst du von den Menüs im Spiel?
Kacke!
Einfach kacke!
Ich hab mich für einen Controller genommen
und Tasten von der Tastatur drin geschrieben, fertig
Du denkst doch nicht, dass du mich hier outscuff spielen kannst
Shotgun, ich pack's net, ey
Lernen die eigentlich nicht raus, dass diese Klassen in jedem Game
geflamed werden ohne Ende
und man die vielleicht nicht mal so OP machen sollte
Vor allem, wenn man im Standardmensch noch diese Brandmunition hat
Das ist richtig hart
Oben ist einer
Achtung, go, go
Kann man da rein?
Och, geil! Das find ich gut
Das find ich gut, wenn's da so Flankwege gibt
Das find ich geil
Wo man mit ein bisschen Movement-Action dann auch durch kann
Ja, so Peterschiff, ey
Outplayed, outplayed, outplayed
Outplayed
Rekt!
Das muss ich mir speichern
Irgendwie freut mich sowas
900 IQ
Oh, oh, oh
Komm her
Ich hör euch da links
Kommt her
Wieso?
What? Nein!
Vereint!
22,5, ey
Ein wenig OP
Nur ein bisschen OP, nicht viel
Ganz klein wenig
Wo geht's denn hier lang?
Leute, war da was von hinten?
Rekt
Moment, war da ein Gegner hinter mir?
Ey, wie krass OP
Das ist der Wahnsinn
Wie er wieder schreit
Komm her
Ich hör dich da rechts
Ich hör dich, ich hör dich
Ich sollte vielleicht mal meine Killstreaks einsetzen
Fällt mir gerade ein
Was mache ich jetzt, wa?
Auf, spawn
Na ja
In your face
Ja
Nächste Bob bei aller Zeit
Ahem
Der Kabuma hat angerufen gerade auf dem Handy
Schuss weg
Rekt
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung
Kommt her, kommt her
Diese Brandmunition
Oh nee
Nach der Runde muss ich mich mal kurz muten
Ich schreibe mal
Nee, nee, ich schreibe mal nach der Runde
Komm her, komm her, komm her
Achtung
Der wird jetzt Outplay, der Typ
Passt doch mal auf
Oder auch nicht
Ich dachte wir machen jetzt die Dinger mit mehr Range rein
in der range rein, dann werden sie gebashed
glotz, ich hab jetzt die killcam nicht anguckt, war ich das?
war ich das in der killcam?
ich hab grad message geschrieben, war ich das in der killcam?
und was zum teufel, noch mal chat?
einfach mal ein bisschen krach machen, damit wir kein chat
ey, voice chat
äh, was war denn jetzt settings?
ich war das in der killcam, guys
was hier mit den grafik settings läuft, mit 100 plus
ok, jetzt guck ich mir das mal an
keylogger ist wahrscheinlich auch in der url drinnen, ne?
hoffe ich mal
jetzt wär ich enttäuscht, null
ähm, ich mach jetzt eh mit linux auf, die ganzen urls, also
chaos
ähm, controls, was war denn jetzt noch mal chat?
chat, deminüs, deminüs, alt deminüs, chat, fuck
t
t war chat, ok
warum sollte ich meine screen refresh rate auf 119,98 herz stellen?
das ist ganz schön, ganz schön fail, übrigens das game hängt bei mir grader
game?
hallo
so, dann nehmen wir mal wieder was nochmal, spielen wir jetzt mal mit sturmgewehr
bayonet charge
oh, das ist gar nicht wie in battlefield
ok, warum, warum himmeln das jetzt?
ey
aah, das game ey
sehr stabil, sehr stabiles game
press f
lass uns mal respect payen
das ist so fail
also gute werbung für das game ist es nicht, weil, ne richtige beta kanns ja nicht sein,
der release ist ja noch nicht, der ist ja quasi um die ecke, um aus dieser beta eh
großartige schlüsse zu ziehen, ist es eigentlich viel zu kurz, das heißt, es ist so ne typische
promotion beta demo, schrägstrich demo
dafür läufts schlecht
ich hab heute morgen extra nochmal nvidia driver aktualisiert und es war sogar im installationsmenü
vom nvidia driver werbung für das neue call of duty, also das heißt, ich geh mal davon
aus, dass die sogar das ein bisschen was optimiert haben
ja, ganz bestimmt, dass da finne facecam hat, es wundert mich eh, der wollte sowas
doch auch nie, also man hat ihn ja schon öfters gesehen als mich, mich hat man ja zwar auch
schon in manchen videos so ansatzweise gesehen oder irgendwo im hintergrund rumstehen sehen
aber der finne wollte ja eigentlich auch nie facecam, deswegen wunderts mich, dass der
jetzt auch mit facecam am start ist, aber er ist cool, oder?
ich sag mal, wäschen, wäschen alter, wäschen, headglitchen, headglitchen, wichtigste, wichtigste
von allen headglitchen, muss real sein, ohne headglitch gehts, ist das wichtigste, lasst
euch das mal gesagt sein, wenn irgendwie einer sagt, headglitch ist noob-scheiße, stimmt
ich, headglitch ist noob-scheiße, wisst ihr, ich hab nicht gehadglitched und schon bin
ich kaputt, hätt ich gehadglitch, hätt ich gewonnen, so dumm das jetzt klingt, das stimmt
sogar, der waffe muss man ein bisschen aimen, was, fuck, da war doch eben noch nix, ne, ne,
ich switch jetzt lieber auf shotgun gleich, der typ, guck mal, der typ hier, der hört
sich bei mir an, als er noch hinter mir war, als ist er neben mir oder vor mir, ganz, ganz
merkwürdig, oh jetzt haben wir, ey das klingt gerade so mega auf den sack, so weil wir so
sehr auf den sack kriegen, bleibt mir leider nix an, was da übrig, wie shotgun zu spielen,
flenken wir mal aus, drum, guck, der machts richtig, der headglitched, dann gewinnt man
auch, was war denn das, jetzt war das, war das die, die, die, die waffe 100 oder die
waffe 28 oder was war das, au, Achtung, der rennt mir jetzt hinterher, typ 100 war das,
ok, jetzt probieren wir jetzt auch mal aus, die hab ich doch hier ausgerüstet, die testen
wir jetzt auch mal, die kriegen zwar gerade absolut krass auf den sack, ist das, das
sei UAB, das ist nix, wo man wo raus geschossen wird, ok, die geht ab, also die waffen fühlen
sich gut an, das haben sie gut, das haben sie richtig hingekriegt, ok, damage macht
der nicht wirklich, und mit suppressor gar nicht, aber den mal wieder runter, aber das
Ding macht auch nicht viel, au, was war denn das, ah SCG, wir spielen jetzt mal für die
typ 100, wobei ich sagen muss, wir müssen auch mal ein anderer Spielmodus spielen, team
dustman schenkt mir ein bisschen zum hals raus, so auf 2 maps quasi oder auf 3, oh,
der kommt hier klar jetzt, alter was ist denn hier los, ich krieg grad krass richtig auf
den sack, die runden davor übrigens gebrochen jetzt in your face, gut die runde direkt davor
war shotgun action, wie findest du das Spiel bis jetzt, ich bin, ich hab echt meine Schwierigkeiten
dazu was zu sagen, also ich, das setting gefällt mir, die maps find ich bis jetzt auch nicht
schlecht, ne, da kann ich mich mit meiner SMG nicht drauf einlassen, das waffen entgegen,
das gefällt mir auch ganz gut, aber irgendwie, und ich kanns noch nicht näher in Wort, weil
der Spielfluss ist komisch, der Spielfluss ist irgendwie komisch, ich weiß nicht, man,
ich mein es war schon immer schwierig zu predikten, so in call of duty, wo Gegner herkommen, aber
es ist, es ist merkwürdig, es ist schwierig, also ich kanns doch nicht so richtig einschätzen,
was natürlich ganz indiskutabel ist, ist auf dem PC, einmal Performance, Menüs, und was
da noch, wo ich mich eben drüber aufgeregt hab, keine Ahnung, ja sebaro, so ist das,
sebaro du verpasst nix, du verpasst grad, dass ich übelst auf den Sack lege, Runden davor,
alles gerockt, und jetzt einfach nur das Maul. Übrigens, wir verlieren die Runde gerade,
weil ich sag, was geht hier gerade ab? Wow, die muss ich auch mal ausprobieren danach,
der kommt jetzt rechts. Warum, ich darf nicht immer rechts rennen, rechts ist so mid range,
long range Waffen, ich muss eigentlich eher links unten hier so flanken, ah hier in die
Mitte ist auch nicht verkehrt, hier langstelzen, jetzt gehen wir oben lang, kill geleashed,
da hab ich auch noch mal meine Kills irgendwie bekommen, oh fuck, jetzt weiß er, wo ich bin,
wo ist der Typ, komm her,
ich dachte er würde mich outplayen,
hab ich jetzt eigentlich schon ne Bombe? Achtung, wir campen jetzt uns mal hier einen ab,
jetzt gebashed, gebashed, direkt, der ist direkt neben mir, ich hab hier was gehört
gerade, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, bam, direkt, Artillerie, besser warten, dass wir direkt
sind, ich hör glaub ich was von hinten, super, also man muss sagen, man hört den Gegner
wirklich viel besser als in den Teilen vorher, jetzt sind wir im Chat losgekallt, gleich
mal Artillerie hinterher, oh bashed, bashed, bam, ich renn da jetzt aber nicht rein, das
wär jetzt richtig in A-Play in meine eigene Artillerie zu rennen, ich in A-Play wär das,
was, Moment, wo kam, ach der stand da in der Ecke, weil ich wollt grad sagen, ich hab
da doch lang geguckt, Alter der Chat, Hilfe, weep Invasion, victory, victory, victory,
victory, eh, ich glaub das Shotgun Gameplay lad ich nachher mal hoch, so einfach, dass
man mal sieht, wie balanced wieder die Shotgun ist, wir machen uns jetzt noch eine eigene
OP Shotgun Klasse, mehr 360s, ich werd's probieren, aber kann man 360s mit Assault Rifles oder
SMGs machen, das geht eigentlich nicht, 360s kann man eigentlich, also die richtigen 360s,
ja also nicht die ehrenlosen 360s, die kann man eigentlich nur mit ner Ball Action Sniper
machen, wir machen uns ne Sniper Klasse, ganz ganz wichtig, ja lass mich raus, ich muss
die Klasse ausrüsten, ja gogo, Sniper, mit Rang 29, ok nimm mal das Ding, kann da eh
nix dran machen, nice, so Spiel jetzt, jetzt wird gesniped, easy win, ganz leichter Spam
im Chat, me weep me spam, modbucker if ban, debated, so jetzt wird gesniped, jetzt wird
gesniped, sag's euch, ich hab meine Sensitivity überhaupt nicht, guck mal, ich hab hier,
einmal übers Mousepad, geradeball und so, das geht nicht, mit der Sensitivity kann ich
keines 360s machen, wie soll das funktionieren, Hardscope, Hardscope wie den letzten Kacknoobs,
die map ist glaub ich für Sniper eh generell nicht so wahnsinnig geeignet, Hardscope, Hardscope,
Moment, das ist gar keine Ball Action, kann das sein, dass das gar keine Ball Action ist,
die ich hier hab, dann damit geht das schonmal gar nicht, ich wollt grad sagen, warum sterben
die nicht, wenn ich draus schieße, Moment, Moment, das ist, ach das ist ne Auto, ne ne
ne, also mit Auto Sniper geht das nicht, dann spielen wir lieber Typ 100 frei, Auto Sniper,
das ist ja halt für die allergrößten Kacknoob, guck's euch mal an eh, Auto Sniper, null,
ne ne, mit Auto Sniper geht das nicht, guckt euch das mal an, Auto Sniper, ne ne ne, Auto
Sniper, wir switchen jetzt auf, Auto Sniper, ah, jetzt müssen wir erstmal die Runde carryen
wieder, carry pants, hallo, wo sie geht noch, ah, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da,
da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, die Gegner kriegen grad so auf den Sack, dass
da nicht viel geht, hinter uns, hinter uns, hä, Moment.
Jetzt hat er natürlich die krasse Head-Pledge-Position.
Hier ist nichts!
Ich wollte mich outplayen. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Mein Team macht die Gegner gerade so schnell kaputt.
Kriegst ja...
Kriegst ja nix ab!
So, jetzt stellen wir uns hier hin und gucken einfach geradeaus.
Oh, ich bleib jetzt hier stehen.
Ich bewege mich jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich bewege mich nicht mehr.
Oh oh fuck, das sind ein bisschen viele.
Flank, flank, flank, flank, flank, flankerino?
Flank, flank, flank, flankerino?
Ok, jetzt kommen sie von hinten.
Ich hab keine Munition mehr.
Munition, gib mir Waffe!
Keine Waffe mehr!
Egal, ich bin eh down.
Kann jemand von euch die Copy-Paste-Geschichte mit dem Balancieren von den Dosen?
Ich finde, das ist die hohe Kunst.
Könnt ihr Dosen balancieren?
Der kommt rechts.
Mein Kill!
Könnt ihr die Dosen?
Macht mal die Dosen.
Alter, bleibt ihr nicht hängen.
Ich hab nicht nachgeladen.
Ich hab den Schalter einfach draufgeschraubt.
Kommt noch was?
Ey, ey, lass mich weg.
Das sind so die typischen Call of Duty Tote.
Bitte hilf!
Nee, nee, nee, Leute.
So geht das nicht.
Die Dosen müssen auf dem Kopf gestapelt werden.
So kann ich das auch.
Ihr müsst die Dosen auf dem Kopf stapeln.
Auf dem Forehead.
Hättet ihr meine Kills?
Alles meine Kills.
Aber ich krieg sie nicht.
Den holen wir jetzt.
Der wird gebashed.
Ich krieg keine Kills.
Das ist denied.
Und dann verreck ich ihn.
Ah, fast. Fast, Silent Pain, fast.
Schön Head Clutchen.
Fuck, fuck.
Was?
Es gibt keinen Nahkampf.
Wir springen dem Gegner entgegen.
Was ich eigentlich ganz gut finde.
Und es gibt ja auch nicht mehr Panic Knife.
Sag mal.
Was?
Wie ich die wegsprayen kann.
Mit der Typ 100 geht das nicht richtig.
Die beste Spraywaffe ist diese...
Wie heißt denn das Ding?
Die kleine schwarze SMG.
Das ist die beste Spraywaffe.
Da kannst du echt über die halbe Map aus der Hüfte sprayen.
Beste.
Oh, oh, ich muss weg.
Warum ich?
Das ist für meine Range nicht gut.
Der Facepeter ist hier.
Das ist das neue Facemember.
Ist der real?
Ist der real, ist der real Face?
Ich denke schon.
Ich denke Facepeter, der wird als nächstes
richtig kühl starten hier auf YouTube.
Da sind Quickscope Montages.
Ich hab ihn gehittert, ich hab ihn gehittert.
Ich denke Facepeter ist hier der nächste
der nächste...
Ich hab vergessen wie die ganzen Facetube einschreiten.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Irgendwie komm ich hier aber einfach nicht klar.
Warte, Bf1 stinkt hart?
Na ja.
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Eigentlich schon.
Ich glaub's ist hier so eine richtige
Shotgun Map.
Das Ding killt ja auch nix.
Ich hab nen Schalldampfer drauf,
deswegen macht das keinen Damage.
Ja, ohne Schalldampfer geht das doch gleich viel besser.
Ja, ohne Schalldampfer geht das doch gleich mal viel besser.
Ahhhh.
Wo ist denn der Typ?
Oh, Bashing.
Was?
Oh, gibt's diese Scheiße hier auch wieder?
Da hab ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf auf Claymores.
Claymores, ey.
Also ich hab immer noch keinen gesehen, der die Pyramide hinklickt.
Ich bin echt enttäuscht.
Oh, such a skill, such a skill.
Hier Face Peter.
Oh, der war gut der Face Peter.
Habt ihr's gesehen? 0,20.
Das kann nur ein real Face gewesen sein,
weil er Trickshots probiert.
So, was können wir jetzt nochmal anlocken?
Was gibt's hier noch?
Also die Waffe suckt.
Ist das hier?
Ok, das ist ne Ballaction.
Dann nehmen wir das Ding.
So, was haben wir ansonsten noch hier schönes zu bieten?
Typ 100, können wir da jetzt was...
Ah, sehr schön.
Scope, Scope suckt, brauchen wir nicht.
Aim down sights, machen wir uns ein ordentliches Visier drauf.
Was bringt das hier?
Gar nichts, das ist einfach nur...
Einfach nur Optik, oder?
Oder?
Moment, oder?
Oder sind das da unten die Perks quasi?
Das sind die Perks?
Ah, ok, verstehe.
Und die Perks sind wahrscheinlich je nach Division anders.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
So, gucken wir mal, wie die Typ 100 ist jetzt mit Visier.
Sieht schon besser aus, das Ding.
Sneaks.
Fast, fast.
Also bei mir ist es nicht gerade.
Zwei.
Jetzt wird geflankt.
Schalldämpfer, Schalldämpfer flank.
Wir rennen jetzt hier drüber, bis Gegner da sind.
Bevor Gegner da sind, sind wir jetzt hier drüber.
Easy.
Oh, das Ding macht überhaupt keinen Damage mit Schalldämpfer.
Ich höre hier Gegner rennen.
Direkt!
In den Arsch, gespornet, verschlossen.
Was?
Loll.
Das Ding macht mit Schalldämpfer wirklich viel Schaden.
Wo kommen die her?
Der Face-Peter ist wieder da.
Okay, okay.
UAV.
Den holen wir jetzt, der kommt hier gleich rein.
Oder auch nicht.
Nice.
Der nächste, der kommt jetzt hier.
Oh, fuck.
Aber jetzt gleich schon mal eine Granate auf den Kopf.
Die Waffe 28 muss auch ziemlich gut sein.
Weil ich so auf Reddit gelesen habe.
Kann man mit dem Ding irgendwie Gas geben?
So Predator-mäßig kann man mit dem Ding Gas geben.
Weißt du das hier mal?
Weil so ist mir das ein bisschen langsam.
So.
Ich höre was, ich höre was.
Ich höre immer noch was.
Ja ist klar.
Voll durch Dauerfeuer durch rennen.
Gar kein Problem.
Und überhaupt kein Problem!
Oder geht das nicht?
Ich fänd das geil wenn das nicht geht.
Geht das vielleicht nicht?
Sind die Killstreaks fest?
wirklich, dass die Killstreaks fest sind.
Was sagst du zum Netcode?
Moment, ich sage zum Netcode, dass ich mir erhofft habe, dass es richtige Server gibt.
Und ich bin mit, also es funktioniert ja, es ist aber kein großer Unterschied zu anderen.
Fuck!
Es ist aber kein großer Unterschied, also manche Hitmarker, also man kriegt manchmal Hitmarker, obwohl der Gegner schon tot ist, man kriegt manchmal Hitmarker, obwohl man da nichts getroffen hat.
Man stirbt um die Ecke, angeblich gibt es Server, aber es gibt Leute, die haben Host Macrations.
An sich, es funktioniert ganz okay.
Sieht man ja, das funktioniert schon ganz gut.
Spray in Prey ist halt saugut wieder, mit SMGs, also vor allem mit der einen, mit der hier nicht unbedingt.
Bombe, ich bleib mal hier drin.
Ich muss weg.
Ich muss weg. Komm her, Headlitch, Headlitch.
Hahaha, schön ins Gesicht gerannt.
Oh, 16-4, so eine richtig gute Runde.
Ich hab da was gesehen.
Immer von der Seite.
Und das links unten ist, glaube ich, das Netcode-Symbol, wenn es laggt.
Der Face-Peter.
Mal gucken, wie viel das aushält.
Oder so, wie sie.
Ich hör hier was.
Die Waffen ohne, ich zeig euch das jetzt mal, also was gewaltig ist.
Welche Waffe ich richtig gut finde, ist die hier, das Spray in Prey aus der Hüfte.
Hab ich die richtige Klasse ausgewählt. Nee, die da brauch ich.
Oder?
Irgendwo hab ich das bessere Hüftfeuer ausgewählt.
Das ist richtig OP. Da kann man über die halbe Map aus der Hüfte schießen.
Kommt euch an.
Warte mal, war das die richtige?
Ich denk mal, die hier, ja.
Da kannst du die halbe Map über die Hüfte schießen.
Aus der Hüfte schießen, nur mit der halben Map.
Oh, das ist schlecht, jetzt wissen sie, dass ich hier lang laufe.
Kommt, kommt, kommt hier. Halbe Mapspray.
Von hinten?
Was?
Und nachdem man in dem Game AD AD strafeln kann, fast so gut wie in Overwatch, ist aus der Hüfte Schießen auch ziemlich gut.
Ich versteck mich mal, Bombe.
Guck so, hast du es gesehen hier, wie man aus der Hüfte sprayen kann?
Ja gut.
Call of Duty Tote sind immer von der Seite.
Ich höre da was.
Jolo, Jolo. Moment, was willst du hier?
Was willst du hier?
Oh, ich hab ne Donation gekriegt, ich guck gleich, ich guck gleich nach der Runde.
Wenn ich vergessen sollte, spend mich voll, weil sowas darf man ja nicht, das gehört sich ja nicht.
Wo ist der Typ hin?
Wie ich ihn nicht gesehen hab.
Moment, ich guck mal Donation.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr bewegen, richtig?
Ich hab, wenn ich nach links und rechts drücke, übelst Input-Lag.
Jetzt gehts wieder.
Was auch immer.
Oh, mehr Gegner.
Oh, dass die Baro hat, danke, 15 Euro.
Die Beta Performance am PC ist eher so mancher als ja, das stimmt.
Die Performance ist nicht gut.
Ich spawn bin und gleich mal ne Granate am Kopf krieg.
Stellst du uns hier mal lang?
Nichts.
Ich dachte der Typ heißt Christian Pfeiffer, das wär mal ein guter Name gewesen.
Ja, die Performance ist nicht sonderlich gut.
Das ist geil, wenn man rausgetappt hat, wenn ich raus tappe aus dem Game und wieder reingehe, habe ich die ersten 10 Sekunden Input-Lag.
Input-Lag, ich drücke, hört ihr das?
Jetzt gehts wieder.
Das dauert dann so 10, 15 Sekunden bis man sich überhaupt wieder richtig bewegen kann.
Also der PC-Port ist wirklich grottenschlecht.
Grottenschlecht.
Warum heißt der Anus? Warum nennt man sich Anus? Kann man da raus was ableiten?
Vielleicht hätt er gerne was in seinem Anus.
Guckt euch das Gespray an. Habt ihr das gesehen? Guckt euch das Gespray an.
So, wir müssen jetzt noch ein paar Kills machen.
Für Bombe.
Jetzt spielen wir mal ein bisschen safe.
Achso, wir haben verloren. Also wieder dasselbe Cod Trash wie jedes Jahr. Ich kann das schlecht beurteilen, weil ich hab die Letzten nicht mehr gespielt.
Zeigen wir mal ein paar Manieren.
Ich hab die Letzten nicht gespielt, ich hab keine Ahnung. Es macht Spaß, das Game fühlt sich aber komisch an irgendwie. Das Problem ist Call of Duty's machen immer Spaß, wenn sie neu sind.
Deswegen.
Aber was hab ich gesagt, wollen wir jetzt machen?
Ähm, ich wollte irgendwas ausrüsten oder irgendwas. Wollte ich nicht machen, wollte vergessen.
Keine Ahnung.
Wo kann man denn seine Killstreaks jetzt...Scorestreaks steht doch sogar ganz fett da. Also, was haben wir da? Recon Aircraft. Das ist das kleinste, was es gibt. Nee, das kleinste ist eine Molotov Cocktail.
Mortar Strike.
Bombe, Artillery.
Care Package, den Kack braucht kein Mensch. Oh, das will ich haben. Das will ich haben. Das sind bestimmt sowas wie Hunde vermute ich mal.
Das sind bestimmt sowas wie Hunde vermute ich mal. Das sind bestimmt sowas wie Hunde aus Black Ops 1. Weil das ist sau hoch, der Killstreak. Hallo 18H. Das probieren wir mal zu erreichen, dass es im Deathmatch immer ziemlich schwer ist.
Lass noch mal ne Runde schneiden. Lass noch mal am Anfang ne Runde schneiden. Ich brauch unbedingt Quickdraw. Wir nehmen einfach jetzt mal die vorgefertigte Sniperklasse.
Moin, ist das ne Claymore? Perfekt. Ich wollte eigentlich genau das gleiche machen, wie der Typ ne Granate rüberwerfen.
Okay, komm mal. Ich will nächstes Mal einen snipen. Will nächstes Mal einen snipen. Hallo? Warum sieht er mich nicht? Lull. Komm her, MonkaS. Hardscope. Hardscope Noob.
Hardscope Noob. Kein Bock mehr zu snipen. Machen wir mal genau das Umgedrehte. Jetzt wird nicht gesniped, jetzt wird getrenched gun.
Alter, was ist denn das? Jetzt wirds getrenched gun. Muss sein jetzt. Es geht leider nicht anders.
Ich hör was. Oder auch nicht.
Oh. Der stirbt jetzt, Leute. Die ist so OP, die shotgun. Guck, zack.
Sogar wenn ich down bin. Jetzt hört es sich wieder an, dass ein Gegner vor mir ist, ist es aber nicht. Was macht der da?
Ich hab jetzt schon so schön draußen rumgelaufen, um ihn zu bashen. Das manchmal hört sich an, als sind Gegner neben einem, obwohl sie es nicht sind. Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Nee, nee, komm, als wäre was ordentliches. Spiel mal ein bisschen Assault Rifle. Wollte ich immer ausprobieren.
Ja, Feuermunition. Der größte OP-Kack im ganzen Game. Was auch immer man sich dabei gedacht hat. Das Ding ist ziemlich ungenau für ein Assault Reifel. Da sind ja die SMGs genauer.
Hinter mir. Oh, oh.
Kann man Gegner anhand ihrer Schrittorten? Ja. Es geht halbwegs gut. Ich finde es geht besser als in den anderen Call of Duty, als in den letzten Paar, die ich gespielt hab. Warum macht das Ding keinen Schaden?
Der schießt auch schneller als ich. Oder kam mir das nur so vor. Atledge. Atledge, komm, ihr müsst jetzt hier lang kommen, Leute.
Irgendwie macht das Ding zu wenig Schaden.
Ah, mal wieder mal eine Spray, ein Spray SMG. Er ist der Affe. Da ist einer drin, oder?
Vielleicht hekt man mal in der Mitte durch.
Was ist denn hier was? Hier ist nichts. Wo ist hier was? Suche Gegner. Ich kriege gerade so krass auf die Fresse, nur auf die Fresse.
Wie gefällt dir das Spiel? Das macht Spaß, aber jedes Call of Duty macht Spaß, wenn es neu ist.
Was zum Teufel geht mir die Gegnern gerade ab?
Das Ding macht übertriebenes Damage für den SMG.
Der Facepeter. Moment, ist der hinter mir gespawnt? Der ist hinter mir gespawnt.
Erste Spawn Position. Jetzt bin ich hinter ihm gespawnt. Das wird immer fairer.
Jetzt ist er hinter mir gespawnt. Die SMGs wurden schon genervt, echt jetzt? Ich habe keine Patch Notes gelesen oder so.
Wir müssen hier ein bisschen was frei spielen.
Der denkt jetzt, ich gehe oben lang. Wo ist er denn?
Das war jetzt nichts.
Oh, das sind ganz schön viele da. Wie viele Gegner bitte? Wie viele waren das? Fünf Stück?
Gibt es eine Burstwaffe? Ich habe noch keine gefunden. Es gibt halbautomate Sniper, Ball Action Sniper, eine Doppelläufige Shotgun, eine Pump Action Shotgun, aber eine Burstwaffe wie die Farmers habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Oh, ich habe den hässlichen. Nee, habe ich nicht.
Warten wir mal kurz, bis wir sehen, wo die Gegner sind. Perfekte Granate. Der Typ lebt noch.
Das Ding macht keinen Damage. Ja, Tremor finde ich auch. Ich hatte auf den letzten Call of Duty überhaupt keinen Bock, das hier macht halbwegs Bock, aber es ist halt neu.
Und es ist halt so, die Leute kriegen ja immer erst mit der Zeit raus, was richtig abfuckt und nervt.
Ich muss hier unbedingt nach der Runde, muss ich mal raus Perks und Killstreaks und sowas in Ruhe angucken.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie lange die Beta noch läuft.
Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass es ein Game ist, weil es ist halt so das typische Stubide Team Deathmatch, zumindest in dem Spielmodus halt. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es ein Game ist, was ich in Jahr spielen kann.
So, jetzt muss ich mir erstmal in Ruhe Perks und Killstreaks nochmal angucken.
Was? Bis 5. November? Ok, das ist ja noch ein bisschen. Kann ich morgen noch ein bisschen streben? Der Anus. Der Name ja. Warum?
Ich finde mein Name ist der beste für Call of Duty, oder? Also für Call of Duty kann man eigentlich nicht besser heißen als die 60 NoseCorp Casual Gamer.
So, jetzt muss ich mir das mal in Ruhe angucken. Killstreaks, das lassen wir mal so.
Das bringt es gar nicht. Das ist quasi ein Heli, sowas wie ein Attackhelikopter. Das lassen wir mal so.
22, welches Level bin ich? Welches Level bin ich? 19, ok. Die probieren wir dann mal aus, wenn wir es haben. So, wie funktioniert das jetzt mit den Parks?
Jetzt mal angenommen, ich... Ah, so geht das. Ah. Ok, das hier unten ist wahrscheinlich je nach Division feste Perks, so wie ich das verstehe.
Und das hier neben sind halt ja Perks, die man sich ausrüsten kann, aber anscheinend nur eins. Was gibt es denn da so?
Das ist hier für MPG Zeug. MPG und Infnoop. Lookout, das heißt man sieht die Namen früher. Das ist Scavenger.
Reload Fast, der Endweils Printing, das ist cool. Take Two Primary, das ist quasi Overkill. Take Two Attachments, ok.
Fire Guns Wild Spore, das brauchen wir. Das brauchen wir für unsere Shotgun Klasse.
Enemy Damage Appears on Minimap. Das ist bestimmt auch nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, das ist gut, wenn man einfach so die Randomness, die es in Call of Duty nun mal gibt, ein bisschen reduzieren will.
Das ist gut, dann sieht man, wo der Typ seine Artillerie hingesetzt hat und sowas. Bang. Na.
Wisst ihr, das verstehe ich nicht. Warum kann man nicht jetzt hier schon hinschreiben, was es macht?
Es ist ja schön und gut, dass ich es erst ab Rang 23 nehmen kann, aber wie wäre es denn, wenn man jetzt schon wüsste, was es ist?
Also das ist ganz gut, im Renn Sprinten perfekt.
So, jetzt machen wir uns noch, ok, das heißt, ach hier sieht man die, die Perks für die einzelnen Divisionen.
Ok. Ja, dann spielen wir erstmal Airborne weiter frei, würde ich sagen.
Oh, das ist für die ganzen Ghost-Spieler. Da weiß ich jetzt schon Sachen, die mich abfacken werden. Silent Movement, das ist so OP, das ist Must-Have.
Also wenn man das vielleicht später rankt und ein bisschen koordiniert spielt, Silent Movement, das ist OP, das braucht man.
Man wird wahrscheinlich rankt später nicht mehr ohne hier Mountain spielen können.
Ok, leveln wir das Ding nochmal ein bisschen.
Das könnte man dafür gut nehmen hier. Take two primary weapons, nee das brauchen wir nicht. Im Prinzip ist Reload faster, echt geil. Machen wir das mal.
Ok, weiter gehts. Ich spiele nochmal eine Runde, Team Deathmatch. Die letzte MP ist ziemlich krass, ok. Ja, das ist gut, ich spiele ja quasi eh gerade Airborne frei.
Ok, dann werden wir die ja demnächst haben, hoffe ich. Bei Level 22 gibt es noch eine. Und dann müssen wir mal gucken, welche kommt, wenn man Airborne hat.
Guck, ich kann jetzt Reloaden. Ah, das ist geil, ich kann ballern, ich kann ballern während ich sprinte, geil. Da stehe ich drauf auf sowas in so Games.
Ok, vielleicht soll ich nicht in drei Gegnern reinrennen, aber das ist geil. Das ist gut, rennen und gleichzeitig sprinten, beste Erfindung.
Komm her, komm her, komm her. Flankt da jetzt mal. Sollen die sich da mal kloppen.
Hier ist ja gar nichts mehr. Jolo. Hinter mir.
Fuck. Rennen und gleichzeitig, habe ich das gesagt, ja. Ich meine natürlich rennen und gleichzeitig schießen, aber rennen und gleichzeitig sprinten ist auch was.
Das ist ja doppelter Boost hier. Steht keine Kills. Oh, das ist geil. Das finde ich super einfach, einfach reinschargen und ballern dabei.
Vielleicht ein bisschen zu aggressiv gerade, so minimal. Was ist eigentlich aus dem Arbeitskollegen geworden, der mich vorfühlt?
Du meinst Felix oder was? Der arbeitet immer noch hier. Da wo ich arbeite. Achtung, die kommen jetzt hier raus, wir haben jetzt gebashed. Kommt her.
Jolo, direkt. Jetzt kommen sie von hinten. Den holen wir uns. Den holen wir uns.
Wir waren leider nicht schnell genug. Fritz wird getroppt. Das ist geil. Das ist so geil.
Sprinten und rennen. Oh fuck, beste. Man bringt sich da halt auch mal schnell in Situationen, wo man auf den Sack kriegt. Moment, war da oben gerade hinten.
Komm her. Ihr wollt jetzt langlaufen, das weiß ich. Oh shit. Das ist zwar geil, wenn man reinschargen kann und dabei ballern, aber so möglichst viel bringen tut es jetzt ja auch nicht.
Man kriegt halt permanent auf den Sack, aber es macht Bock. Chargen und ballern. Das habe ich schon in jedem Call of Duty gerne gemacht. Am besten jetzt noch unendlich Sprint.
Am besten jetzt noch unendlich Sprint und dann ist alles gut. Verdienst du mit YouTube trotz Inaktivität noch mehr als mit deiner eigenen Arbeit? Nee.
Da hängt ja einiges davon ab und vor allem, wenn man halt nicht aktiv ist, das ist ja nicht nur, dass man dann quasi keine Views und neue Abos kriegt.
Das ist dann auch nicht sonderlich interessant für... Alter. Für irgendwelche Firmen oder so dann da was zu machen. Ich wollte ja was mit Alien mehr machen, aber da haben wir jetzt erstmal gesagt, ne, dann lassen wir mal bleiben, bis ich wieder ein bisschen mehr mache.
Das habe sogar ich vorgeschlagen, weil das hat keinen Sinn. Das sollen ja alle auch was von haben. Jetzt muss ich mich mal ein bisschen konzentrieren wieder.
Oh, oh, oh. Beste. So geil. Sprinten und ballern dabei.
Moment. NA-Aim. Ah, fuck. Juckt die Nase. Hast du Freitag noch frei wegen YouTube? Nee, ich habe Montags frei. Immer Montags frei.
Ich würde jetzt ja mal gerne wieder ein bisschen was reißen gerade. Aber Team Deathmatch, ein paar Stunden, das ermüdet einfach so.
Was ist denn da hinter mir los? Gucken wir mal ob wir da leben drüber kommen. Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, weißt ihr was das Schlimme ist? Man kann jetzt nicht hier aus der Lobby raus. Weißt du wie lange du noch streamst? Keine Ahnung, solange ich doch Bock habe.
Gerade macht es keinen Bock. 8-9, das ist ja hier. Das ist das letztes Game noch nie gespielt. Ich stream jetzt schon zwei Stunden. Also ein bisschen mache ich noch. Das ist ja erst zwölf.
Und dann kann ich einfach nur ein bisschen Asia futtern. Aber erst später. Ich habe jetzt noch Zeit. Der Rüdiger Franziskus. Nee, Rüdiger Franziskus sozusagen. Kann man ja nicht aufstecken.
Also bis 22 spielen wir auf jeden Fall noch, weil ich will die letzte SMG ausprobieren.
Heißt das hier, dass die zusammen in einer Party sind? Oder was heißen diese Köppe? Ja wahrscheinlich.
Was der Kapun zur Zeit zockt? Keine Ahnung. Ich habe mit dem Krieger eigentlich nichts groß zu tun.
Ich kann verstehen, dass er lieber strebt anstatt YouTube zu machen. Also ich sehe ihn ja so oft auf Twitch.
Weißt du noch wie der Shop hieß, wo du damals Black Ops 1 vorbestellst? Das war so ein Schweizer Shop. Games only? Gibt es sowas? Kann das sein? Sowas total überteuertes?
Sowas total überteuertes war. Das hat damals in die 70 Euro gekostet.
Hat damals 70 Euro gekostet und war halt trotzdem schneller da als deutsche Shops, weil sie es halt vor Release schon verschickt haben und wahrscheinlich DHL an der Grenze gegeben haben.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Ey, wo sind denn die alle? Die PPSH spielen wir danach auch mal wieder, die war auch extrem gut.
Die Waffe hört sich an ohne Schalldämpfer, wie mit Schalldämpfer. Kann das sein? Ja, ne? Hätte ich keinen Unterschied. Nee. Die haben einfach den Sound verwechselt.
Ja, links. Die Waffe ist über Range. Richtiger Sack.
Was sitzt da in der Ecke? World of Games? Ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, Games only hieß das.
Oh, wir haben EFA gekillt.
Jetzt spawnen sie hinter uns, das ist Call of Duty, darf man nicht vergessen.
Immer so, die spawnen immer hinter einem. Nee, okay, unsere Leute spawnen noch da. Da kommt rechts was.
Komm her, komm her.
Aha.
Geht schreckt. Am besten ist langsam, habe ich echt das Gefühl, man bleibt einfach an einer Stelle stehen und guckt in eine Richtung. Jetzt kommen sie wahrscheinlich von hinten.
Jetzt kommen sie von hinten.
Ey, Call of Duty Tote, immer da, wo du nicht hinguckst und denkst, dass da eigentlich von da keiner kommen kann, kommt einer. Ich habe alles gecheckt, nix war da. Bam, tot.
Oh, wir sind ein bisschen unterlegen kann das sein, so ein ganz kleines bisschen. Bam, ich dachte, der stirbt wenigstens.
Geiles Timing, Hans, bestes Timing.
GG, wir wollen 22 werden. Der liegt da oben, ich weiß, dass der da oben liegt. Komm her.
Ey, ja, mein Team ist auch. Den Unterzahl ist halt echt schwer.
Den holen wir uns noch.
Ja, natürlich, von allen Seiten. Aber ich meine, es ist halt einfach mal drei gegen sechs. Zwei, zwei gegen sechs, aber drei gegen sechs.
Ja, ich finde es gut, dass man die Schritte, finde ich auch, gut, dass man die Schritte wieder hört.
Ey, das geht halt gar nichts. Die, ich muss die, die Type, die Type 28 oder Waffe 28 Ding muss ich aber ausprobieren.
Das macht ein absolut OP Eindruck, das Ding.
Ah, wir haben wieder Leute, yeah.
Achtung, jetzt wird er, jetzt wird er geschreckt.
Krass, geschreckt. Komm her. Da kommt noch einer. Und links.
Ich wusste, dass du links bist. Ich habe noch vorher geschossen, aber nie, aber nie.
Was ist das? Guckt euch mal die Hand, habt ihr die Hand gesehen? Ich habe gerade die Hand von der Waffe, guckt euch mal die Hand an der Waffe an. Die sieht hässlich aus.
Guckt mal, guckt mal, guckt euch mal die Hand an. Was ist denn das? Das sieht echt kacke aus.
Ja, natürlich. Okay, die wollten es nicht anders. Die wollten es nicht anders. Ja.
Wenn ihr das so wollt, dann spielt ihr das als Shotgun. Ist halt ein Handschuh, ja, aber ganz schön ekeliger Handschuh.
Dann mit der Pumpgun. Gürtelstraße, Louis Vitor Store. Zahl die Kollektion bar, flieg auf Sponsor.
Dann mit der Pumpgun, wenn es sonst nicht geht. Dann mit der Pumpgun. Why so laggy? Because fall of duty.
Meinst du den Stream oder Meinst du hier Gameplay? Weil der Stream ist echt FPS. Mehr geht nicht.
Die sind so OP, die Brandmunition. Guck mal hier, such skill, such skill, such skill.
Bam. Kleiner, einfach Raff Profil Text. Ja, die wichtigen Sachen muss man ja auch können.
Ich hab Hunger. Ich geh mal kurz gucken wegen Essen, ich bin 2 Minuten wieder da. Bis die nächste Runde wieder los gehts.
So, weiter gehts.
So. Ja, endlich mal ne neue Map. Also neu, heute noch nicht gespielt. Es gibt 3 Maps, wenn ich das jetzt richtig gesehen hab.
Gibraltar, diese Schneemap und die.
Wir bringen das hart. Ihr denkt jetzt, dass ich links da angehe, ne?
Triple, triple, triple, wo ist der nächste? Bam. Was? Was? Was? Such skill.
Moment. Ich bin quasi direkt vor der Nase wieder gespawnt.
Ich bin quasi direkt vor der Nase wieder gespawnt.
Ich guck mir das grad in der Vorschau an. Ich hab null Frametrops.
Wir stellen das jetzt mal um. Wir stellen das jetzt mal von Game Capture auf Window Capture um. Was natürlich nicht funktioniert, ne? Vielleicht gehts dann besser.
Window, ne, ich will Window fullscreen. Probieren wir das mal aus jetzt. Ich stell das jetzt mal um von...
Ich kann Call of Duty nicht Capture'n. Mit Window Capture geht noch mit Game Capture. Keine Ahnung, was da ist.
Ich darf übrigens dem Game wieder nicht rumklicken. Ich glaub das Game ist wieder abgestürzt.
Hallo, Game. Game. Ah, jetzt ist es aus. Vielleicht ist es jetzt besser, wenn ich neu starte.
Also wenn ich das Game neu starte, vielleicht gehts jetzt besser gleich. Mein Rechner spackt auch richtig rum.
Also das liegt nicht am Stream, das muss an dem Game liegen. Ich sehe es hier auch. Also ich hab es in Game auch ab und zu mal ruckeln, aber so schlimm kommt es mir nicht vor.
Was hältst du vom Spiel? Ja, macht Spaß. Ist halt ein neues Call of Duty, was am Anfang immer Spaß macht.
Oh ne, mein Mikrofon wieder. Ich mach das Mikrofon leiser. Das ist wirklich nervig, dass das Game immer das Mikrofon umstellt.
Das hackt mich richtig ab. Da denk ich doch nicht dran.
Also wenn ich mir jetzt die Vorschau angucke, läuft das besser.
Ah, Game ist wieder abgestürzt. Oh man, ey. Der PC-Port ist so krütze. So ne Scheiße, ey. Kann doch nicht sein, dass das Game jedes Mal abkackt, wenn du deinen Rechnerchepp anguckst.
Was ist denn das für ein Scheiß? Ich mein, man kann doch erwarten, dass man ein Spiel wenigstens, egal wie scheiße das Game an sich ist, man kann es doch wenigstens spielbar machen.
Oh, jetzt muss ich das Mikrofon umstellen. Abgefucktester PC-Port, den ich seit Langem gesehen habe.
So, ich hoffe es läuft jetzt besser.
Sag mir mal, wie es jetzt läuft. Sledgehammer PC-Port als Lull, ja.
Was war denn das letzte Sledgehammer Ghosts? Ne, ähm. Was war denn das letzte Ravens of Sledgehammer Call of Duty? Was war denn das nochmal?
Edwin's Warfare, ne? War das Edwin's Warfare? Das war auch kacke. Hatte es nicht einen 60 FPS-Log und so ein Dreck?
Könnt ihr euch daran erinnern, wo sie gesagt haben, ja, wir lieben PC-Spieler, aber Foff-Changer gibt es nicht.
Und dann hat jemand ein Tool programmiert, was quasi in der Config-Datei das Foff geändert hat. Danach haben sie gesagt, ja, jetzt wird er gebannt.
Also ich glaube, sie haben nie einen gebannt, aber man kann ja auch schon seine eigenen Käufer wrecken.
Also wir gucken uns gleich mal, ich gucke mir mal nebenbei auf dem zweiten Bildschirm die Spielerzahlen an.
Steam Stats. Hallo? Steam? Ich darf nichts schreiben.
Das Game hat meine Tastatur gekrappt. Ich darf nichts machen auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Team Deathmatch. Team Deathmatch. Team Deathmatch.
Steam Stats. Stats. Stats in Deutschland.
Call of Duty war 46k im Vergleich zu PUBG mit einer Million.
Null.
Aber ich habe wieder Input-Lack. Auch klasse.
So läuft das Game jetzt besser oder immer noch so kacke?
Weil ich habe keine Frametrops und nichts, ne?
Das sieht aus wie unschöne 30 FPS. Okay.
Da, keine Ahnung. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es an meinem OBS und Stream liegt.
Eher schlecht, okay. Weil in meiner Vorschau sieht es super aus.
Na gut, wirklich schön sieht es bei mir auch in der Vorschau nicht aus.
Was ist denn das für ein Kacke?
Weil meine CPU ist auch null ausgelastet. Also außerhalb, was für Call of Duty das. Keine Frametrops und nichts.
Ich mache mal kurz Stream aus und wieder an.